bonsoir
fidèle à notre formule qui veut que nous
amenions sur ce plateau de télévision
tous les animaux du monde même les plus
gros nous allons retrouver ce soir deux
vieux amis dont nous avions fait
connaissance il y a près de trois ans
deux vieux amis qui sont un hippopotame
et un rhinocéros qui ont pris quelques
kilos depuis l'hippopotame vous le
connaissez ces gros léon qui coule des
jours heureux au zoo de coucy-lès-eppes
et le rhinocéros cet automne que vous
connaissez aussi mais qui a grandi
tototte une femelle rhinocéros qui a un
excellent caractère comme vous pouvez le
constater ce qui lui vaut de rester en
complète liberté au parc zoologique de
thoiry
je voudrais ajouter un mot si nous avons
rassemblé sur ce plateau rhinoceros et
hippopotames ce n'est pas pour une
parenté zoologique quelconque mais parce
que avec l'éléphant l'hippopotame et le
rhinocéros font partie d'une caste la
caste des seigneurs de la brousse
qu'aucun animal n'est pas même les
choses nous attaquer alors voici ce soir
les seniors de la brousse présenté par
marie jo van buck et pierre préfère
maître de recherche au cnrs vous
permet-il qui a fait faire que totale
des vols pendant quelques instants la
veille avec ces mesures le soigneur de
paris m'a raconté une très jolie
histoire la concernant c'est vrai
qu'elle est arrivé très jeune dans la
réserve de soieries elle avait quelques
mois alors son soigneur l'a élevé
complètement au biberon
lamy en compagnie d'un éléphant de cinq
ans pour qu'elles s'ennuient pas ce
qu'était gentil de sa part
et ensuite quand tu as eu un nom la
relâcher dans la réserve sont en
soignant l'a perdu de vue et l'a
retrouvé que douze mois plus tard et
figurez vous que tout est là
parfaitement reconnue de loin est là
elle s'est approchée en courant avec son
allure un peu lourd mais mais très
affectueux et finalement elle elle a une
mémoire d'éléphant pratiquement oui mais
écoutez ce que vous me dites là ne
m'étonne pas du tout parce que les
les rhinocéros ne sont pas du tout si
stupides qu'on le prétend et ils
s'apprivoisent parfaite surtout lorsque
justement ils ont été élevés en quelque
sorte par une mère artificiel alors là
il la reconnaît ce même bien longtemps
après si vous les lions pendant quelques
instants tototte pour parler de l'espèce
si mes souvenirs sont exacts rhinocéros
vient de 2000 grecque alors innocent
signifie nez et ses roses ça veut dire
cornes de rhinocéros est donc un animal
qui portent des comptes sur les lieux
absolument
vous l'avez défini en 2001 mais je dois
quand même là vous interrompre un petit
peu car en fait il ne s'agit pas
exactement d'une corne les cornes que
nous avons vu jusqu'à présent chez les
cervidés ou chez des bolides et était
une production de l'os frontal qui
pouvaient recouvert ou non d'un étui
dans le cas de la corne du rhinocéros
il s'agit simplement d'une production
épidermique une sorte de grosse
callosités qui est plein et qui
justement puisque c'est simplement une
production de la peau n'est pas attachée
par aucun os ni aucun ligament elle peut
casser mais elle a également repoussé
très facilement c'est ce qui s'est
produit justement chez total c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que sa corne antérieur est
très courte
c'est parce que elle a déjà était cassé
une fois et celle qu'on voit ici c'est
une repousse la corne finalement été
considérée autrefois comme un puissant
aphrodisiaque et c'est ce qui explique
on a énormément rochas et les rhinocéros
oui cette corne entre guillemets on peut
dire a failli provoquer la disparition
des rhinocéros
parce que la pharmacopée chinoise but
attribué toutes sortes de vertus et
notamment celles comme vous l'avez dit
d'être aphrodisiaques réputation
absolument pas fondées
n'empêche que les rhinocéros ont été
massacrés un peu partout en particulier
en asie
puisqu'il y a en fait cinq espèces de
rhinocéros dans le monde deux en fait
3 on agit et pour terminer peut-être
avec cette corne est ce qu'on
différencie le mal de la femelle à cause
de la corne ou est-ce que ça n'a aucun
rapport
absolument pas le mal comme la femelle
ont des cordes et là vous voyez une des
espèces dont je vous ai parlé un
rhinocéros indien donc un rhinocéros
asiatiques
nous voyons bien reconnaît sahraouis à
sa carapace
oui exactement bien reconnaissable à sa
corne unique c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle rhinocéros unicornes est
également cette peau très épaisse
formant des replis ou sorte de caparaçon
ces séquences ont été tournées dans la
dernière réserve où subsistent des
rhinocéros indien forte heureusement il
y en a encore environ 300 et cette
réserve est situé dans la salle à la
frontière à la frontière chinoise à
proximité les rhinocéros que nous
voulons voir paraissait créatif
pourtant ce ne sont certainement pas des
animaux créatif non une sont nullement
craintif et en tout cas justement pas
ceux de la réserve de quasiment gars que
j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter car ils
sont même agressif on visite cette
réserve à dos d'éléphant dans d autres
herbes comme vous avez vu est très
souvent les rhinocéros charge les
éléphants au lieu de fuir
chose curieuse une chasse ils chargent
pas avec leurs cornes comme on pourrait
le croire mais en essayant de mordre
l'éléphant avec l'or dans leurs canines
qui sont extrêmement acérées et qui
provoquent des blessures très profonde
tous les cas de tôtes ne montre aucune
velléité combative heureusement je ne
veux pas lui faire de peine mais je
trouve qu'elle est construite un peu a
enfin bizarrement elle a encore énorme
des pâtes un peu courte
taillieu minuscule elles vont pas très
bien voire d'ailleurs l'issue d'une
nation sont en effet petit ce qui n'est
pas grave mais surtout comme vous voyez
ils sont placés sur le côté et de ce
fait l'animal dont de surcroît la vue
est obstruée par la présence de
ces cornes l'animal ne voit pas très
bien ce qui se passe devant lui
ce qui fait que ces réactions sont
souvent assez imprévisible voyant
quelque chose bouger devant lui aussi
bien un buisson qu'un être humain ou
tout autre objet mobile il charge ne
sachant pas très bien si la faire un
objet inoffensifs ou un ennemi de son
espèce et lala pulis contrairement à
l'éléphant de tout à l'heure enfin tout
au moins il ya beaucoup moins de flics
ou les 10 euros pour une séance d'asie
que vous imposez à la rue nouvelle
défend aussi à la police et c'est vrai
vous avez dit qu'il y avait deux sortes
de rhinocéros d'afrique ou alors qu'elle
sorte avant nous ici est bien ici nous
avons l'espèce dite rhinocéros noir
évidemment un état par un pari qui
paraît pas spécialement noir mais c'est
tout simplement parce qu'il existe une
autre sorte de rhinocéros qu'on appelle
rhinocéros blancs et qui d'ailleurs
n'est n'est pas plus blanc que celui-ci
et noah à laquelle il explique ainsi v2
sont gris mais il se trouve que le
rhinocéros blancs à une lèvre très large
un museau carré en quelque sorte
et quand les colons hollandais ont
débarqué en afrique du sud
eh bien ils ont vu comme sursis
rinôçérôse que vous voyez dans la
réserve africaine de thoiry ils ont vu
que ces animaux avaient une lèvre large
écart est alors ils l'ont appelé wright
nice comme wright signifiant l'argent et
on a traduit blanc eric alors les
anglais ils ont traduit weit par white
qui signifie blanc et nous évidemment on
a suivi et on a dit rhinocéros blancs et
part en position l'autre on la perd une
séance noire
vous allez me dire que je cherche une
explication à tout mais y at il une
explication au fait que tout est
justement et la lèvre elle très allongé
alors que l'autre n'avait large et bien
vous avez raison de chercher une
explication et plus
ou parce que en fait si le rhinocéros
blancs à une lèvre large écart et c'est
parce qu'il vit dans la savane dont ils
broutent l'herbe avec sa lèvre qui agit
en quelque sorte à la façon d'une
tondeuse
alors que le rhinocéros noir lui vit
dans ce qu'on appelle le bush c'est à
dire la brousse épineuse d'afrique et se
nourrit essentiellement de rameau de
branche est de buissons et chose
curieuse d'ailleurs surtout de lui sont
extrêmement coriace et épineux et qu'il
saisit avec ses lèvres mobile et voyons
très fragile
oui oui justement là je pense qu'ils ont
été filmés dans la réserve dans boselli
en tout cas vous voyez que l'habitat du
rhinocéros noir est plutôt les régions
arides
il vit en solitaire où ils préfèrent
vivre en troupeau une vive jamais en
troupeau ils vivent en groupes familiaux
n'est ce pas le mal la femelle le plus
souvent même la femelle avec son jeune
d'il ya quelques années et son jeune
récents dans vous voyez ce sont des
groupes familiaux s'en sont jamais des
troupes ou comme l'éléphant et ses
animaux se font dans le bush se trace
des pistes extrêmement nettes qu'ils
suivent de façon régulière et évidemment
il vaut mieux pas se trouvaient sur leur
passage
ni surtout comme dans un cas que je
connais installé sa tente justement sur
une piste de rhinocéros ça ça vous
promet des des mésaventures plutôt
désagréable vous demandez ce qui s'est
produit pour les habitants de cette
terre est bien dans le cas que vous
évoquez une s'est produit rien de grave
leur innocence en plein milieu de la
nuit est passée au milieu de la tente
il a été affolé parce qu'ils se trouvent
et recouvert par la toile de tente forte
heureusement il n'a heurté personne mais
il s'est sauvé en emportant la tente les
rhinocéros sont d'ailleurs en mauvaise
réputation
ce sont des animaux quand même plutôt
agressifs ils sont dans l'ensemble assez
agressif en effet comme je voulais dit
cela est dû surtout à leur mauvaise
visibilité qui ne leur permet pas de
distinguer exactement ce qu'ils ont en
face d'eux et puis il faut dire aussi
que
évidemment pour le rhinocéros le
meilleur moyen de défense c'est
l'attaqué
nous allons le voir voyons d'ailleurs
cette fois ci il va être capturé les ans
il a taxé pour se défendre
oui il se défend souvent de façon assez
vigoureuse puisque mais ici ce ne sont
pas des chasseurs mal intentionnés
puisqu'il s'agit de la capture pour un
autre a probablement sont en effet 100
présent toute l'apparence vous savez que
les rhinocéros sont très demandés dans
le jardin zoologique
mais évidemment leur capture n'est pas
toujours aisé il fasse combien celui-ci
par exemple bon je pense que celui ci
qui est du noyau qui a l'air d'un gros
mâle adulte je dois peser une tonne et
demie et une masse de cet ordre comme
vous voyez est capable de culbuter un
véhicule ou moins aussi lourd qu'elle on
cite le cas même de locomotive ayant été
renversé par des rhinocéros est ce qu'il
ya plusieurs façons le capturer les
rhinocéros ou est-ce que la façon dont
nous voyons et la façon classique en
fait il ya trois façons si vous voulez
ou bien avec des fausses placer sur leur
passage ou bien à l'heure actuelle avec
les les fusils anesthésique ou bien
justement à l'aide de lassos fixée à
l'extrémité d'un morceau de bois d'un
bio extrêmement lourd et qui paralysent
l'animal dans sa fuite
cette façon évidemment n'est pas si les
choses dans ce cas tu es parce que quand
on s'attaque à une femelle s'est elle
devient redoutable sans doute pour
protéger son petit oui parce que le
petit évidemment ne peut pas fuir aussi
rapidement il
il est obligé de rester en arrière et la
femelle ne peut faire autrement que de
revenir pour chasser les gens qui
s'attaquent à son jeune
ici on va que le lasso a été passé ou
coup de l'un des animaux d'un jeune mais
justement un autre probablement la mère
attaque le camion essaye de le libérer
faut sans doute des heures pour en venir
à bout
et bien voici notre deuxième vedette
bigler on ne voyait aucune analogie il a
5 ans il apaise une bonne tonne
il va continuer à grossir je pense il
pourra au moins doublé puisque
l'hippopotame peut dépasser deux tonnes
et même en atteindre 3 et peut vivre une
bonne quarantaine d'années je voudrais
continuer le petit jeu que j'ai commencé
tout à l'heure hippopotames et bien cela
signifie cheval d'eau est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette définition
cheval je ne vois pas très bien pourquoi
sauf disons ça fasse un peu allongé et
ses naseaux saillant
car en fait du point de vue géologique
les hippopotames n'ont rien à voir avec
les chevaux il se place plutôt à côté
des suidés c'est à dire des sangliers
des porcins que vous connaissez n'est ce
pas il ressemble aussi un petit peu un
rhinocéros tout à l'heure dans la mesure
où il a lui aussi un très gros corps des
pâtes très courtes un peu
disproportionné et des yeux lui aussi
très petit les yeux sont petits mais
surtout mais par contre ils sont placés
de front donc ils voient bien ce qui se
passe devant lui et surtout vous
remarquerez qu'ils sont saillants est
situé à la partie supérieure de la tête
ce qui permet à l'hippopotame de se
tenir sous l'eau on ne les sent dépassée
que ses yeux et ses narines
donc il peut respirer peut voir ce qui
se passe autour de 8 mai lui même
demeure invisible
par contre le terme d' aquatique lui
convient fort bien pas tout à fait
disons aquatiques mais amphibie parce
que la nuit potable passe disons la
moitié de son existence dans l'eau et
pourquoi
eh bien chose curieuse pour un animal
africain il souffre beaucoup de la
chaleur et ne pas naître ne possède pas
de mécanisme physiologique
on appelle régulateur c'est à dire qui
lui permet de résister à la chaleur est
par exemple grand lyon que nous avons là
sous vos yeux souffre beaucoup de la
chaleur du studio et le pompier de
service a passé son temps à la rose et
pour son plus grand plaisir
je vous signale que c'est la seule façon
que quand les ont apprécié l'occar à
coucy-lès-eppes
la [ __ ] on arrose tout le temps il a
horreur de l'eau parce qu'il a été
capturé très jeune c'est peut-être le
seul hippopotame qui n'aiment pas l'eau
il a été capturé très jeune et il n'a
jamais vécu dans l'eau alors attention
je précise ce n'est pas que gros les ont
même pas lourd mais il n'aime pas aller
se baigner dans une rivière
parce que il a été élevé hors de long
loin de dijon de tout rivières et de ce
fait il a peur d'entrer dans l'eau
comprenez c'est une sorte de perversion
de l'instinct on rencontre chez des
animaux captifs par contre comme vous
voyez il aime toujours être arrosé donc
et notre ami tech la rose rick tous les
jours dont dans son jardin zoologique de
coucy-lès-eppes c'est un animal de
fleuves en l'état le voyez fréquemment
dans l'île il vivait dans le nil où je
vous ai dit il a été malheureusement
exterminés mais on le trouve encore dans
beaucoup d'endroits d'afrique surtout
évidemment là où il est protégé où sa
chasse est interdite car il a été
énormément massacrés pour sa chair qui
est très délicate et sa graisse aussi
qui est très recherchée mais dans les
réserves on en voit encore d'immenses
troupeaux le long des fleuves le long
des marigots boueux comme celui ci et on
voit parfois des rassemblements de
plusieurs centaines d'hippopotames oui
contrairement au hainaut sérieux ce
n'est pas un solitaire loin de là il ya
même une réserve la réserve queen
elizabeth où l'on a dénombré quatorze
mille hippopotames vous voyez un peu le
rassemblement que ça peut faire
et il faut dire que les pâturages ont
beaucoup souffert de cette densité de
grands animaux
à quelle époque naissent les jeunes
l'hippopotame il ne sera peu près toute
l'année parce que pour l'hippopotame si
vous voulez la la saison en fait n'a pas
grande importance puisque lui justement
il possède un moyen de lutter contre la
chaleur en restant dans l'eau aux heures
les plus chaudes et la période de
gestation dure combien de temps
huit mois pour le rhinocéros la même
chose ah non le rhinocéros sont
étonnamment plus longue de 16 à 18 mois
selon les espèces ici on voit un
hippopotame se nourrir sur la terre
est-ce que c'est sa façon habituelle de
se nourrir il ne prend aucun aliment
dans l'eau très rarement ils mangent
parfois quelques heures d'aquatique non
en fait il s'alimente essentiellement à
terre et avec sa bouche énorme
ils t'ont l'herbe d'une façon
extrêmement efficace après le passage
d'un hippopotame vous avez l'impression
vraiment une tondeuse à gazon est passé
ici on voit encore une de ces curieuses
association la nature d'hippopotames se
promène à côté d'oiseaux qui ne sont pas
du tout et farouche non ce sont des
cormorans jeu j'ai l'impression même
qu'il y à une eau à d'égypte fonds
commune en afrique
mais ces animaux n'ont absolument pas
peur de l'hippopotame qui est
parfaitement inoffensif espaces et même
souvent on voit des oiseaux couvrir sur
le dos des hippopotames et et ramasser
les insectes qui s'y trouvent ou
simplement s'y reposer puisque
l'hippopotame dans l'eau pour eux c'est
une petite île accueillante n'est ce pas
est absolument sans danger
est ce qu'il n'ya pas également des
parasites sur la peau des rhinocéros
comme des hippopotames
est ce que ce n'est pas là que viennent
se nourrir par exemple de will et les
oiseaux qu'on appelle pitbull et il est
aussi d'autres oiseaux qu'on appelle les
oiseaux buffle celui qu'on voit là n'en
ai pas c'est une poule d'eau qui court
dans l'herbe aquatiques et les oiseaux
dont vous avez parlé eux en effet
recherche l'éthique des grands animaux
mais que cela en ce qui concerne les
rhinocéros
parce que l'hippopotame lui était un
amant dépourvu de parasites externes
oui que l'hippopotame lui aussi aime les
fleurs c'est un hippopotame hippie oui
là je le vois nous les voyons plutôt
baignant parmi les jacinthes d'eau qui
en fait ne sont pas des plantes
aquatiques je vous signale que ce sont
des plantes sud-américaines pour envahi
toutes les rivières d'afrique le voici
également
oupoh est-ce qu'il s'immerge quelquefois
contre complètement et qui peut rester
sous l'eau ils peuvent rester sous l'eau
on pas aussi longtemps qu'on le dit en
général ça ne dépasse pas 4 minutes mais
ils peuvent très bien marcher sous l'eau
avec des mouvements extrêmement lents
comme ceux d'un astronaute en état
d'apesanteur sa formidable gueule qui
finalement nous allons l'avoir mieux
peut-être tout à l'heure et terrifiante
mais n'est pas destiné à absorber
tellement de grosses nourriture
absolument pas je vous ai dit les
hippopotames strictement végétarien et
le fait qu'il bail comme ça souvent et
ouvre sa bouche est plutôt en quelque
sorte un moyen d'intimidation vis-à-vis
des autres hippopotames et également
vis-à-vis de ses ennemis potentiels
il prend un bain il doit aimer se
baigner s'amusait quelquefois dans
l'autre les hippopotames sont très
joueurs mais en fait si vous voulez il
ya aussi une question de vie familiale
ils ont en quelque sorte au sein du
troupeau leur place extrêmement nettes
et lorsque un individu cherche à prendre
la place de l'autre celui là évidemment
le repousse et cela produit cet effet de
balai constant de changement de place
que vous voyez nous avons peu parlé
encore et on parlait des moeurs et
hippopotames mais peu d amour des
hippopotames
est ce qu'il se passe également dans
l'eau oui la reproduction
aussi bien l'accouplement que la mise
bas ont lieu dans l'eau le jeune donc
voit le voit le jour si on peut dire
dans l'eau il est immédiatement poussé
par sa mère qui le porte à l'extrémité
de son nez vers la surface où il prend
sa première bouffée d'air et puis
également il se repose sur le dos de sa
mère de façon à avoir la tête qui émerge
hors de l'eau mais par contre
l'allaitement a souvent lieu dans l'eau
je pense comme cela se passe dans
d'autres espèces animales que la saison
des amours et parfois précédées de
combats violents qui doivent être
redoutable chez les hippopotames
oui surtout que
le mal et popo tam est polygame -il à
raismes de disons 10 à 20 ou même plus
femelles et ce harem ils le défendent
vigoureusement contre l'intrusion de
tout rival les combats se passe
évidemment dans l'eau puisque qui
peuplent tam est un animal aquatique et
ils sont très violents et très
spectaculaire on voit souvent d'ailleurs
des vieux mâles entièrement couvert de
cicatrices
car les morsures d'hippopotames peuvent
infliger des blessures profondes
nous assistons ici un combat est ce que
il arrive parfois qu'on peut vous dites
des blessures profondes est ce qu il
arrive parfois qu'un hippopotame
extermine totalement l'autre
je ne pense pas vraiment cela doit être
tout à fait l'exception mais comme je
vous ai dit les blessures sont souvent
profondes et évidemment le vaincu en
général n'insiste pas et prend la fuite
avec l'intention évidemment bien ferme
de recommencer à la prochaine occasion
les hippopotames sont ils des animaux
très dangereux on a vu la mâchoire tout
à l'heure elle paraissait
impressionnante la mâchoire de
l'hippopotame est évidemment une arme
redoutable surtout à cause de ses
canines qui sont souvent très développé
et qui sont toujours très tranchante ce
sont elles qui inflige ses blessures
auxquelles je fais allusion mais en
général
l'hippopotame un tempérament paisible si
des accidents arrivent parfois avec des
êtres humains c'est parce que ces
personnes se sont interposés entre l'eau
ou de l'hippopotame avait l'intention
d'aller et la terre ferme d'où il venait
également il arrive que des pêcheurs en
pirogue qui passe à proximité d'une mère
hippopotames ayant sont jeunes ou d'un
mal un peu irascible soit renversée par
un hippopotame et même coupé en deux par
ses mâchoires énorme
jean jacques turck du coup nous apporter
un merveilleux documents qui confirment
ce que vous venez de dire nous allons
voir il a filmé un hippopotame qui se
baignait
et dans les fleuves tchad et des
africains jouer avec et joue avec de
façon étonnante ils montrent vraiment
sur cette bête comme si c'était à cheval
oui je vous dirais que ces images ne
m'étonne pas du tout parce que
personnellement il m'est arrivé de me
baigner dans des mares juste à côté
d'hippopotames qui ne manifester aucune
animosité
très souvent on a vu des hippopotames
comme ça a été le cas à brazzaville
récemment à côté de fort lamy
on a vu des hippopotames s'installer à
proximité d'une agglomération et vivre
en excellentes relations avec les hommes
je dois dire malheureusement d'ailleurs
cette amitié est sous la plupart du
temps été trahis car il se trouve
toujours des petits futés oui plus malin
que les autres
il a envoyé une balle fort peu glorieuse
à mon humble c'est ce qui est arrivé je
crois à l'hippopotame que nous voyons
ici vous ne m'étonnait pas si c'est
l'hippopotame qui était à côté de fort
lamy c'est ainsi que sa carrière
pourtant sympathique s'est achevée
[Musique]
il existe un autre hippopotame que nous
n'avons pas cette fois ci dans notre
studio
en fait il est nettement plus petit il
aurait pu devenir beaucoup plus
facilement que celui là oui il est plus
petit mais il est beaucoup plus rare
six états l'hippopotame nain que vous
faites allusion l'hippopotame nain est
une autre espèce d'hippopotames mais ce
n'est pas tellement une espèce aquatique
c'est en fait surtout un animal
forestier il vit dans les forêts denses
du liberia et de la côte d'ivoire et il
mérite assez justement son nom
d'hippopotames non puisque sa taille ne
dépasse pas celle d'un gros cochon et il
a les moeurs similaire d'un hippopotame
non pas du tout c'est un animal
extrêmement solitaire qui vit par couple
ou à la rigueur enfin par deux ou trois
n'est ce pas et il est extrêmement
farouche extrêmement méfiant il a de
bonnes raisons d'ailleurs pour ça parce
que il est pourchassé et c'est un animal
politique de forêt une forêt dense
il pèse combien il pèse dans les 150
kilos voyez au maximum je crois que nous
avons nous allons pouvoir quitter
maintenant à la fois tototte et big léon
car l'émission s'achève j'aimerais vous
demander si ces animaux sont menacés si
les rhinocéros sont en voie d'extinction
se porte très bien et s'il en est de
même pour les hippopotames et bien
commençons par l'hippopotame et disons
que son sort est pour le moment
relativement optimiste puisque ils
existent en grand nombre dans les
réserves et dans les endroits protégés
en ce qui concerne le rhinocéros noir on
peut dire qu il en reste environ 3000
surtout en afrique orientale
le rhinocéros blanc lui est beaucoup
plus menacé
et puisqu'il n'en reste que quelques
centaines dans de réserves quant aux
trois rhinocéros asiatiques leur avenir
est vraiment extrêmement qu'on produit
le rhinocéros indiens ne représentait
plus que par 300 exemplaires
quant aux rhinocéros de java et de
sumatra
il en existe une vingtaine seulement de
chaque espèce
autrement dit ils sont pratiquement en
voie d'extinction
donc on peut dire qu'il faudrait plus
intéressés à l'ivoire en aucune façon et
il faut se rappeler que la corne de
rhinocéros n'est pas la folie diack
absolument pas toutes les analyses l'ont
prouvé si de l'argent mal placé que
d'acheter une corne de rhinocéros et
bien merci
puis fr et merci bigler au mercy toth
[Musique]